la pandemia de kobe 19 ha complicado el
proceso electoral en eeuu se espera que
una gran parte de los votos se emitan
por correo ya que los ciudadanos buscan
evitar el riesgo de contagio en los
centros de votación pero el virus
también provocó un aumento de la
votación anticipada presencial sobre
todo por parte de las personas
preocupadas de que su voto se pierda al
enviarlo por correo
yo voté por correo hace un par de años y
fue muy conveniente pero obviamente con
todo este alboroto sobre si funciona o
no funciona pensé por qué no levantarme
a hacer la fila y hacerlo en persona
ahora estamos aquí porque no nos
arriesgamos a que los ataques que
socavaron el servicio postal o los
intentos para desalentar los votantes
tengan un impacto en minnesota un estado
donde tanto el presidente de la chiang
como el candidato demócrata joe biden
tienen eventos de campaña este viernes
se espera que los residentes voten por
correo con cifras récord un voto que
trans promociona como fuente de fraude
potencial estamos hablando de grandes
porcentajes de votos que van
va a haber fraude es un desastre esta va
a ser la estafa de todos los tiempos
generar desconfianza ante el proceso
electoral y en el voto por correo la
única posibilidad contemplada para
muchos ha sido la estrategia del
mandatario y para ello vayan es un
intento de chando por socavar la
integridad de la elección ni más ni
menos